[Music]
as the crowd enters for the next game
it's the smell of popcorn and hot dogs
and the announcer introducing the teams
the cheer of the crowd and they have no
idea that the night before the
conversion crew is working feverishly to
completely change over the building from
a sold-out concert into Nets basketball
[Music]
the conversion crew they're the unsung
heroes right nobody sees them their job
is to go from concert mode into
basketball the team's going to be in at
8 o'clock and they can't know that there
was a concert here when the concert ends
the first thing that the conversion crew
does they take the floor and remove all
the chairs call that chair strike as
soon as the chair strike is done we'll
start to work on TV platforms larger
press sections they're like small
structures themselves where you might
have four or five guys on it for four
hours to completed
Barclays Center has to truck elevators
to bring vehicles into the arena there's
85 feet long and they hold 85,000 pounds
each truck pulls out onto a turntable
that's 95 feet across we turn the
turntable so the trucks line up with one
of the four bays and then they come back
in it is a choreographed dance with
forklifts coming back and forth and
trailer trucks spinning on the turntable
and going into the truck elevators
they're the only way in and out of the
building for anything that won't fit
through the front door it's about 3:00
or 4:00 in the morning before our team
can really take the floor and start to
focus on the basketball installation
this floor is a sipper it starts with
one row down the middle and then you can
split off both north and south with two
separate crews you can build it more
efficiently we have 40 conversion
workers than two full-time supervisor
we'll line our center row down that will
be row a the north side is single
letters on our core pieces and the south
side is double letters and they'll roll
out in a sequence each piece slammed in
within slammed in pin until you finish
on opposite corners of the court
[Music]
the work it's extremely physical it can
be demanding on the body they have to
make sure every line on that court lines
up perfectly the expectations are
perfection the amount of money that goes
out onto that basketball floor with
players salaries the court has to be
safe at a meeting trip hazards or any
gaps I think that's where the pressure
comes in but we can go into any
situation and be successful overnight we
were doing conversions it took us 15 to
20 hours and now we're doing it in six
to eight we like to get done before
anybody else shows up I even caught a
couple the Nets players on occasion
coming in early and walking down on the
side of the court and checking it out
and I don't think they even know all the
love that goes into putting that court
together that they plan on every night
after the conversion is complete we're
100% ready for a basketball court is
down the hoops are up all the seats are
in place and buildings ready for the
next game that night
[Music]